gang we got a big announcement a special
announcement kippy and i are related
and we got a special drop in december
21st and boy do i mean special it is all
of our favorite moments from this year's
keep it moving tour plus some behind the
scenes footage it's gonna be fantastic
yes guys it's available on our youtube
page uh so go if you're watching now
subscribe if you listen go subscribe
it's gonna be dropping december 21st
it's gonna be good we need the army of
garbage to rally behind us unite and get
this thing on the moon baby tell
everyone
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that they grow up
to be classy yeah they're just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host stage foley
coming at you on a beautiful day down
here at antony's basement she's upstairs
in bed back
it's up on the couch last night oh at an
ikea yeah yeah i had an idea i got you
all right
she was gonna get pinched but she knew
to secure she's trying to wait out the
security guard to do a little home alone
running around
all right uh but turns out security
guard newer bottom line we got a couple
meatballs in the freezer so check it out
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me can't really tell if he's
amused this week
the writer's room's going to hear about
this god damn it making me look bad in
front of the boss give it up for kj
kevin james ryan this one's off to a
goofy start already what's up guys
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are true
true the [ __ ] roof baby it's cooking
and then obviously i would be a jerk off
an [ __ ] a [ __ ] if i didn't
mention the greatest website of all time
patreon.com are you garbage check it out
you can get bonus content episodes
episodes of hard feelings live streams
the whole nine [ __ ] yards shout out
to the yam family
yes siren have a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good we love them
you love them t-bone mcscruffins toby
mcbuttons
dudes
we got yanny p in the house you know
what that means we're gonna have a good
time and you think we're not you got
another thing coming let's go
all right thank you
try a cup of decaf will ya
jesus christ you were ricing me i
panicked
i'm more monster for breakfast for you
but the long hair couldn't be more
accurate ladies and gentlemen because we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest back with us
again today he's a part of the family
he's going to be answering your
questions he is the host of long days
give it up for the one the only giannis
what's up jeff the kid johnny p it's
good to be back with the wawa twins
i said before i'll say it again i love
that name
the wawa kids it's good to be back in
auntie's basement yes sir in midtown
[Laughter]
no manhattan sorry we're in south jersey
guys i'm going to get a hanging
cop we're in shot races we're in cherry
hill all right
i just got your [ __ ]
wawas in a coffee black
nice classy touch by the way thank you
for the coffee of course well you're
coming you're a classy guy i mean kind
of you you can walk in both worlds what
are you doing at the house for coffee in
the morning are you you're
you're probably a french press kind of
guy what do you got the nespresso like
clooney no well what we did was we
started
with the lazy swedish
uh swedish you know the uh what the
cupcakes the keurigs keurigs they're
swedish are they swedish securing sounds
it's finnish something it's it's nordic
they made it up there yeah yeah they
made it you made it up there up at the
north park yeah right now yeah it wasn't
a guy with a tan i'll tell you that
it was invented in massachusetts
it wasn't wrong our friendly neighbors
to the north made that this kid's from
westchester westchester that might as
well be poland to him
and we started with that but then we
started thinking about the hot plastic
they're trash that that's the
and you taste it you taste it and then
um
actually we we brought the carrick
machine from my apartment in brooklyn
which i can't believe i lived in now by
the way which is now looking back
looking back i'm like how the [ __ ] do we
live in this box sure well you got
stretched now you got yard you got
please got a little property you know
him and version they're out there in a
conch we're in a country furzie's got a
piece of property back there i got one
too yeah
he's old man he's old man i got one too
yeah i mean come on wait you got that
kind of square footage in the back wait
well it's square footage you're talking
new york terms yeah i don't deal in
square footage he's an acre man i deal
with anchor stuff
that's i deal in grown up numbers that's
grown up
i got 37 million square feet of yard
back there
you just put it in the actor trying to
make it in new york terms
i'm a grown family man i got i count
things in acreage
smoking my pipe on the north 40. you
know what i mean
i got one point two and you got one
point two you always say one point two
you put it you put the point two in
there yeah of course just
i would go i got a buck and a quarter
one point two yeah nice little front you
can stretch you can stretch your legs
out in the front and the back and
my next door neighbor has a horse and a
pony really
yeah
nice
where's it running
aqueduct where you guys putting it down
to be honest i don't know if she has
enough uh acreage i mean she's got i
think she's got one anchor i don't think
that's enough for a horse you've said
acre way too many times
stuck the last time i'm gonna say acre
yes having a neighbor with a horse can
either be real classy or like what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah because it's tough
if you're in a co-op
[Music]
you'd be surprised you go up to the
projects in the bronx you'll find a lot
of exotic animals you know that's the
thing in philly there's they call them
like the philly cowboys there's just
dudes in north philly with horses yeah
that they just keep them in abandoned
lots i remember my buddy angela told me
that you know cause you know wherever
you got like uh puerto ricans they
always have their uncles coming from
puerto rico and they'll if they're from
like the countryside
yeah they'll just bring ducks and put
them in the bathroom yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he told me once his uncles got
drunk and
and uh my buddy angelo lozado rest in
peace and they got hungry after they got
drunk and they didn't have any food so
they just killed one of the chickens
that they had running around the
apartment yeah i mean they treated their
uh apartment like it was like its farm
oh let's go to the chicken they just
went in the bedroom which is like where
they killed one of their roommates
and they [ __ ] just
skinned it and ate it right there damn
yeah that's [ __ ] hardcore
back to the coffee yeah what are you
doing now so now now i've gone classy
and very recently what are you doing
recently during that trip you guys have
been in the house a little over a year
right yeah a little over a year so it's
got to be coming together because you
just when you did the show a year ago
and you had just recently moved in you
were just settling it up yes that's
right so i've been in there about a year
and a half
and so
last couple months
uh we decided to try to upgrade it it
was daunting because it comes with work
but i was determined i was like you know
because
when you become a boring married guy the
quality of your coffee becomes very
important of course yeah all those
little things become top parts of
conversation with your other married
friends that's what you are doing
comedian so you always talk about like
hey how's it going kind of coffee we had
the keurig but we switch it up you know
to our plastic how's that restaurant
yeah oh you got that car what's that
like yeah that gas station's pretty good
over there
you actually talk about which gas
stations i know who's their guy who's
their ac guy he'll turn you on i'll do
redo the driveway this guy's good yeah i
got your driveway sealed should i do
that should i not he's in a neighborhood
oh god i'm cheap yeah who do you use for
your gutters
[Applause]
i've been meaning to egg shoes yeah
so we decided you get a pony like that
you got a pony guy yeah
yeah she rescued it
yeah you can't impress me i already
asked her she rescued it
she rescued her was it mixed up in a
drug how do you [ __ ] rescue a pony
i don't know how you rescue a pony but
she's a rescue pony
he was working in a tattoo shop
on saint martin's stripping at night
what the [ __ ] you rescue a pony
yeah i guess you were gonna put the pony
down out there riding fences yeah it's a
small pony dude
and uh it's like it's it's got kind of
looks like a dog it's the size of a dog
yeah but it looks like a horse which is
kind of it's like a [ __ ] horse yeah
that's what a pony is i know yeah the
dwarf that lives behind uh foley's house
so we upgraded and we uh we went to
um
we got the drip we got the drip machine
like like a proper coffee pot machine
coffee publishing like an old school
diner you know oh nice you know you get
the you get the coffee there filter
is fresh
she's good it's fresh
i'll make a fresh pie make a fresh pot
i'll put a pot on there you got a coffee
pot we got a coffee pot yeah we got a
coffee pot but then we went we went
further we started with just like buying
the ground bag okay then i went i was
like let's get a [ __ ] grind let's go
all the way out the grinder the chopper
now we can have breakfast yeah exactly i
want to get this thing as fresh as
possible smell the bacon cooking too
so we got the grinder now we grind them
and we drink them and let me tell you it
makes the difference
it really
takes it from a 7 to a 10.
it makes the difference dude freshly
ground [ __ ] guatemalan beans
right now we got some from yemen oh
really i'm starting to get into the
countries yeah this sounds like
specialty markets i need things to do
yeah you're not getting this at
[Laughter]
so one could say that you're enjoying
your time in the burb you're settling in
i don't even i can't even believe i
lived in this goddamn rat home
we all have stockholm syndrome to live
here i can't believe i've been here
you're getting the paper delivered uh no
what is this 1972
i have a phone how you doing mr pappas
did you just
that was a question from someone who
just woke up out of a coma
you got the paper together
you still watching the honeymooners on
channel nine extra extra read all about
it how's your buick
what happened at night rider last night
having a nice conversation i'll tell you
what happened at night rider uh knight
rider uh mowed down a bunch of people in
wacosha wisconsin oh jesus christ
it was the car that did it
every headline car wasn't a night rider
car was it well i'm just not saying a
car had a mind of its own if you looked
at if you looked at all the headlines
from that tragedy it was just like yeah
car drives
through yeah you're like okay i guess it
was the kit
that was mr feeney right that was his
voice
mr phoenix two you guys are too old for
that no i'm pretty sure it was uh uh
higgins from magnum p.i who was the
voice of that could be wrong buttons
checking
he was mr feeney and a boy meets world
also shot in philadelphia shout out to
the wawa kids
the [ __ ]
twitter i didn't know that that was set
in philly damn i gotta get into that
show
[ __ ] 35 years too late on it
oh god any improvements to the house
since we talked last did you redo the
basement did you put anything right
there i redid the basement you're really
full redone
really full redone guys up there you
have like a walkout basement because
it's real hilly over there yeah i'm on a
mountain yeah i know i've seen i've
driven you've been up there
yeah of course you should see them too
out there i mean it's like crazy yeah
it's like that scene in goodfellas when
they're in jail together
i will go over his house i wear croc
yeah i know yeah and i'll go over his
house you're that close yeah i mean i
could walk to his house they're all in
the same mountain three minutes three
minutes that's right wow yeah i was over
this obviously the versi you know we've
talked about it a bunch the version
fourth of july party yeah these two
bozos out there small yeah send the kids
he's got his doll he brings his dog over
are we doing dinners back and forth all
the time dinners what's that i go over
at night
i go over at night with like a couple
truly's it's like real sad suburban [ __ ]
that's good suburban stuff yeah it's
good i walk over 16 year old girl
sneaking out
[Laughter]
it's like that see the truman show where
he comes over with just like a case of
beers
half a six-pack yeah i heard you sad
hey paul hold you i heard you had a long
day paul yeah go drive some golf balls
off the old bridge
[Laughter]
so i'll just i'll just i don't know
paulie i always wanted to get out of
here
i'll go over in crocs and pajama pants
yeah just roll clothes
i don't brush my hair when i go over
there i just really yeah like it's a
little like side door privileges do you
pop by or do you text hey i'm walking
over [ __ ] walking like kramer dude
how how close a friend you are with mr
versi cause he's a finicky guy he's not
letting anybody walk into this he's yeah
he's very he has to you have to be
vetted yeah you have to be vetted it
took me like six years so you're rolling
in i roll in roll in
front door front door yeah front door
front door shoes off
uh no no shoes he doesn't require his
shoes do you ever catch him at dinner
i've caught him at dinner i've caught
him yeah i caught him at dinner i come
in he's usually like watching tv he's
like he's one of those guys he gets
comfortable and he doesn't move yeah i
remember
when verzi gets comfortable he looks
like he's in a hospital bed
he looks like he's actually like about
to ring a bell nurse
like
he's uh he kicks we we're both two lazy
greek kids i enjoy being lazy gets like
a bad rap dude it's a good time
especially as i get older i've
transitioned into being like i'm getting
lazy yeah that said like american things
made my living lazy yeah what are you
doing what are you doing it's like why
do i got to be doing so where am i going
yeah i'm going to the grave why don't
you calm the [ __ ] down you're creeping
me out with all the things you're doing
slow it down hotshot
disney plus peacock that's what i'm
doing i'm zipping around
i'm trying to watch the game and relax
yeah exactly i'm what it's sunday i'm
not doing anything you know what's funny
about i noticed about living up there
though is that uh especially when you're
coming from new york is that the
service expectation is a little lower oh
like it's just like because they
supposed to come on it's like
everybody's first day yeah we fired like
four housekeepers before we just
understood like oh it's just less good
yeah yeah yeah my wife was like they did
one thing wrong my wife was like
you're fired and then another you're
fired and then by the fifth one i'm and
then i'm like look i think they're all
the same bad
it's not new you all went to the same
school yeah it's like everything's a
little more laid back it is yeah because
it's not that fast-paced you only got a
choice of a few it's not like new york
where like sure you serve one meal to
one bad person your restaurant's in
jeopardy sure yeah it's like there's
four restaurants they put a hair on your
food
you know it's like [ __ ] stadium
prices got a christening here in two
weeks you should have the chicken what
do you want
housekeeper that's nice that's very
close how many days a week once every
two weeks i mean i'm not talking
do you clean for the housekeeper like
are you like you gotta straighten it
are you cleaning it at all when's the
last time you had a vacuum cleaner
never dude
i used to clean the apartment okay
basically the apartment is a lot smaller
square footage yeah right we're dealing
with a smaller square that's like point
zero zero zero one acres
yeah acreage that's uh it's not you're
not doing well no not doing well at all
acreage and park slope stuff dude my
phone no ponies out there
my apartment's probably like half the
size of my basement
yeah probably yeah i mean how do we live
like this for our dream i don't know
it's time cause you never lived like
this before right as long as you keep
going in the right direction right now
you're back in that apartment then
you're gonna be in trouble right right
but how did you guys feeling go moving
from it's tough it's class out there in
south jersey
i was down there in middleville
you know from going to the cherry hill
wall
i was uh it was tough yeah but like
you're also so blinded by the dream like
i moved up here and slept on a couch for
let me ask you guys could you guys ever
afford a meal in haddonfield
oh haddenfield it's nice that's nice
stuff yeah
there's hattonfield new jersey because
it also hadn't filled piano new jersey
that's trash when there's two of the
same things it's right outside it's like
cherry hill-esque i don't know it's
[ __ ] classy really yeah i feel like
you guys walking around their cops would
just drive slow behind
you know that
slow creep
they're talking if they make a run for
it i got the fat one where you guys are
going like are they following us i got
an aunt that lives over there uh
and it is it's like the trashy
that's you make that's like the big
thing you make a couple of bucks yeah if
you were born if you were born and
raised in the city make a couple of
bucks yeah you move out to jurors right
that's what you do that's how it goes
and now it's all just like dirt bag
guineas and stuff like that right right
right yeah i've made the natural
progression especially in new york like
he said the floor somebody's kitchen
floor roommates ba ba ba one bedroom
with my girl now two-bedroom with my
girl you're moving up somewhere i'm okay
yeah and i'll tell you something i
appreciate that extra space in the
two-bedroom you having a little office
walk in there after a shower yeah dry
off it's nice is that what you do in
your office that's your work you take
them
well you know what you're welcome thank
you i'll say you're welcome because i
feel like when the history hyenas
patreon went down you guys shot up a
little bit shout out to the hyenas baby
once we crumble people like where do we
go who do we support we're already on
the site you know what i mean i already
got 10 bucks allocated to go somewhere
so we got you the coffee what the [ __ ]
i'll validate the parking yawning calm
down and tim dylan were like chat tim
got away more than we did we got a
little bit of run off that timmy d is
going a-okay yeah kid's all right he's
doing fine i feel like he owns patreon
now
they gotta do like they gotta be calling
him every week like hey you're not
moving right everything's still good no
let's get you to the doctor check check
out your health yeah he probably uh he
calls them to make sure that they're
okay
you guys are still running right because
i could always take my [ __ ] business
to my own website
oh man that dude's doing it yeah okay
kit let's talk about ladder real quick
ladder in these uncertain times you want
to make sure that you and your family
you're protected that's why you got to
look into a little term life got to take
care of stuff that's right you got to
get your insurance straightened out make
sure you're not leaving anybody holding
the bag
high and dry yeah uh ladder is 100
digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork and when you apply for three
million in coverage or less uh you just
need a few minutes a phone a laptop to
apply ladder smart algorithms work in
real time so you find out if you're
approved instantly ain't no waiting
around
uh if you prefer money if you prefer to
talk to a person the team of licensed
agents doesn't work on commissions so
they're not gonna upsell you no hidden
fees you can cancel at any time um
finally since since life insurance costs
more as you age now is the time to cross
it off your list so go to ladderlife.com
garbage a day and see if you're
instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage do it
yeah
how about that brooke linden brook
lennon classy love that brooklyn we tell
you something gang holidays are right
around the corner you want to look like
a rock star knock someone's socks off
without someone's pillow cases off yeah
drop a little brook linen on them uh-huh
brooklyn uh started with betting now
offers all the essentials to make every
corner of your home next level comfy
we're talking
five-star sheets were there that just
started now the collection of must-haves
include everything from dream decor to
cozy loungewear and their new line of
slippers they got you from head to toe
in a bedroom and a bathroom wherever
you're going hey you want a pair of
brooklyn and slippers
oh it's like two weeks ago my toes
they were nice enough to send us uh some
bed sheets they're fantastic you feel
you're staying at a five-star resort you
know what i mean and then i went out i
liked it so much i bought the towels on
my own i got his and her towels it's
like they're like weighted blankets
these things are heavy plush the whole
nine yards i gotta get in on it hotel
level um
so
go to brooklyn.com use promo code
garbage for 20 off with a minimum
purchase of
dollars give the gift of comfort this
holiday season and save while you do it
that's brooklyn b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
enter promo code garbage for 20 off with
a minimum purchase of 100 do it what are
you waiting for he's doing all right
we're all doing all right everyone's
doing our which is nice
you're on a mountain i'm on a it's out
there and you guys that's a big thing
i'm 20 minutes away i'm 34 34 minutes
from the city door to door dude that's
like what's the wind
we got an suv no i got a tesla
classy oh yeah four wheel drive in that
yeah four-wheel drive in there really do
you have autopilot i do have autopilot
do you use it of course i use it
you don't have that thing and not use it
wait hold on you can get a tesla without
the autopilot yes yeah you're a [ __ ]
bozo
that's like having a tesla with the
rolled up windows what the [ __ ] are we
doing
what's the point right yeah i want the
[ __ ] smoke grenades in the grease gun
what are you nuts
[ __ ] spy hunter over here
you can get it is what does i assume it
costs less yes so yeah that's like that
porsche boxster [ __ ] they do it like uh
with software upgrades yeah so it's like
you buy the standard now the i got the
three got the antivirus on there what do
you got you could look at the empty cap
360.
just that that tell me that you're
trying to pretend like you know about
tesla when you don't have a tesla that
was it
i'm gonna man by the way you got your
email on there what do you got
you play games on that thing what's
happening what grubhub what are you
doing ordering from your car
can you you can
well i'm out
hey musk get your [ __ ] together
i think should be able to make burgers
in the back seat
those things ain't cheap right well
that's the thing the one that i got
it that's the thing that's how they get
you it starts at like 37. i got the
letter
i got that on me uh as tim said he's got
the motorcycle
funny jokes because uh ben his producer
has one too it's the same one i got
which is like the lowest model and he
goes that's cool you know teachers have
to have cars too
[Laughter]
but it starts at like 30
i think it's like 33 now okay but here's
the thing you don't get the then you
need the long distance option which is
like
the batteries the batteries then when
you're one of those bozos out on the
jersey turnpike charging up like an
[ __ ] next to a roy rogers
with the actual plug you can actually
plug it into a socket yeah yeah
like like a socket
like an air i can plug it in there yeah
really it takes like 14 years to charge
and he can only make it to the wall
but what is that 220 yeah
i don't even know i don't know voltage a
lot of double hays yeah
oh anybody got an iphone charger my
car's out of cash
i need the five charger the five you
know we got the old school john
wait where are you juicing this thing up
at the crib the garage then that's where
they get you so you got to pay another
13 like 10 to 13 grand for the long
distance option so then you're up to 50.
so what's in the house is there a little
like and then you got to get the charger
which is 500 and then you got to get
installed by an electrician that's 1
500. so by the end of it you're going
like oh yeah they got me yeah elon got
me you're in for like 70 probably jesus
but you know it's like uh
you know you make a payment you put down
payment down and then you got you know
you get car payments like everything the
car payments my car payment's only like
300 something what yeah i'm like 275 for
a kia right now yeah i'm upside down in
a kia yeah but here's the thing you
would said up there in the burbs you get
what you get
now who ca who's who's fixing tesla's up
there in the sticks some money up there
so probably good point
um
that's the downside to having a test
is that they're not like everywhere yet
yeah so you gotta take it you gotta
charge gun valley you gotta like play
[Laughter]
i'll be back in two weeks
yeah you have to like plan your trip
based on where you can charge up so like
sometimes takes you a little out of your
way that's crazy so a full juice at the
house how long do you got about four or
five hours six hours to charge it up
full
so usually
how far do you got to drive oh i could
drive to the city and back and then some
i'm not good at math so like a couple
hours
a couple hours of driving it's like 240
miles or something yeah it's 240 that's
the max right i think so i think so it's
in that area 240 miles that's like a
half a tank of gas yeah i don't know if
i like that is there any kind of backup
batteries in there anything no i mean
you go you know what happens if you do
run out you're out what you're just
stopped that's it that's it but then you
can call tesla someone's got to come
charge what do they tell you or they got
like a little booster pack together
tesla a guy you could call guys so
they'll come and they'll give you a
little juice
those guys are right now this ain't four
this ain't 40. yeah that's a that's a
tank of gas i mean elon musk knows what
he's doing he's got to give you a tank
of gas so take a gas in right yeah 400
400 miles yeah that's the most i don't
know if i have 400. i i think i might
have 240.
you know it'll get it gets me like
almost
to philly
that's only like 120 yeah i don't know
what i'm talking about to be honest with
you
it sounds like a guy it doesn't sound
good who's never been in a tesla i've
got to be honest with you i got the
[ __ ] autopilot yeah i got the long
distance i will go i can only get the
mickey d's in back but still got long
distance nights and weekends i'm [ __ ]
killing it what are you talking about
grease the free tesla to tesla whatever
you need i googled it before i got here
no i'm a guy i i pulled up in a camry
i'm just
the numbers are tough for me i like i'm
a picture guy you're not a numbers man
i'm a picture yeah you're more
conceptual yeah that's what i picked up
on youtube
yeah i'm not good with the numbers where
are you dropping the autopilot uh on the
when you're on the highway you can't you
know i don't have the full autopilot oh
god this guy's thanks i don't have the
full-on the full autopilot costs another
10 grand what and i'm like i don't
that's when you self-drive you you can
have it come to you you can summon it oh
no one's got to be in it nobody's going
to beat it you could summon it
that's like batman [ __ ] that's batman
[ __ ] but i don't need that for 10 grand
are these things she's basically saying
i can't afford that
but have you ever squashed anybody or
anything like that i'm sure they have
but it's it's always not because of the
car it's because some person decided to
fall asleep while they're going 100 yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know so but i think
there might be you can't do that what's
the point of the autopilot good point
that's like fancy cruise control yeah
it's fancy that's what it does it goes
with traffic you know it slows down
speed based on traffic and uh but my so
mine is auto but it doesn't change lanes
and all that that's another 10 grand
that i'm not willing to can't change
lanes not willing to pay that because i
don't need it
aka i don't have it
i can't kill you okay my wife will kill
me
aka just can't afford it
she's whipping in a jeep she's nice
cherokee jeep love it yeah white both
our cars are white nice yeah yeah yeah
we want to let let neighbors know we're
around yeah white pops yeah white is a
next level trashy too yeah it is like
russian mafia [ __ ] yeah whenever you're
a white car you look like just the wife
of like a firefighter or something yeah
the white mercedes out in the story
there's plenty of them yeah that in the
illegal balcony in u-turn
the mercedes and the bmw is a i've
noticed a great car
to compensate for the fact that you
don't have a lot of money but you want
to show off
you can get in there at a low price
especially like a youtuber
yeah rocking a certified yeah you see
that a lot now p like you know class you
know ben's is classy
i want to do i want to do a benz i think
i switched i think i'm a ben's man next
time who's cleaning the tesla you get
you take it and get it done yeah take it
to the car wash
not a [ __ ] animal
i'm not hosing it down myself i didn't
know if you did well that's part of the
thing in the burbs on a sunday night
paul versus he cleans his own car no he
probably makes it spotless he takes it
to go get detailed
he's a maniac with it he's it's italians
with their cars you're not detailing i
don't detail no
huh i don't detail i like it clean but
there's water there's empty water
bottles in my car
there's a horse you know my car looks
like you were human can you rip burnies
in there no i don't know strict no
bernie's position no no you're a snooze
man
which reminds me i'm about to do for one
would you let your friends smoke in
there no
no i'm not a [ __ ] animal that's crazy
smoking in the car snooze i feel like
i'm on a job i feel like about a job
interview for how
how classy i am welcome to the show
popping that thing here that's what
you're showing that's not doing any help
dude what is that you just popped snooze
yeah
oh my god original sweetest they look
like those snap things that you throw
yeah that's for ninth graders at
homeroom
yeah i let my daughter play with that
too
it's actually become one of her favorite
toys she shakes it
daddy's medicine
my wife always rips it out of her hand
go play with the tin honey
i gave you i gave you snooze what more
do you want from me you know i'm one of
those idiots who every time like you
know i'm at banana republic and they're
like you want to save an extra ten
percent you sign up for the credit card
i've given my social security number to
the gap like a hundred times really yeah
and so i got your hand up and macy's
doing that and then you give them your
phone number and then you keep getting
these calls
i get like a hundred marketing calls a
day we're all getting slammed it's out
of control but who who [ __ ]
zuckerberg who passes up the extra ten
percent on the banana republic everybody
everybody nobody's that that's something
i have to say they're giving you ten
percent up front so they can char in the
fee everything they're making that 10
back in like two months it's a good
point are they getting you on the plane
with the credit card too
signing off have you ever signed up on
the plane no i don't never right no
johnny don't lie to me no i never signed
up no
i never whip out any i no on the plane
i'd coach i'll do your coach man yeah
middle seat coach
jesus i go for the lowest looking for
trouble huh i go for the lowest price
when i it's a guy with nothing to lose
right there middle seat coach goddamn i
mean
i remember once we got uh
i was on a plane flying into westchester
and like the wind that's what they do up
there too they're flying to westbrook oh
you do yeah bill gates airport yeah
that's what him and versi do wait you're
taking the commercial flies up there
i'll do a commercial and then i'll do a
connecting just so i can fly into the
smaller airport really you'll hop on a
[ __ ] puddle jumper one of those
little weirdos
driving a propeller yeah
[Laughter]
i gotta wear these headphones i hate it
they say legally i gotta win a headphone
you're hopping a [ __ ] commuter
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah i know the layout in the north
carolina airport those things are
frightening
i got a layover in trenton yeah
i know i know the bartender's name in
atlanta
yeah i got a weight threat damn yeah
i'll do six hours just to be able to fly
in there to avoid the water wow yeah
look well i don't wanna i wanna avoid
the main airports at this point yeah man
but uh yeah so i we were flying into
there
and uh
it was bad wind like the worst wind i've
ever seen
and the plane did like a one of those
yeah like a full like it was listening
to the fat joe leaned back yeah yeah a
little wobbly yeah and i was in the
middle of trying to shake a tail yeah
and the girl next to me started freaking
out she's like oh my god oh my god
what's happening and she looked at me
and like grabbed my arm and i was like
i'm in a middle seat on a jet blue
flight yeah listen i can't you're asking
me what's going on i haven't even
figured out how to [ __ ] get an aisle
i'm basic economy right now what are you
looking at me asking me what's happening
i wasn't allowed to bring a carry on i
look like i understand [ __ ]
aeroeconomics or whatever it's called
i know what it's called
you just saw me pay eight bucks for a
set of headphones
you're asking me lady we're all gonna
die 15 15 bucks for a sprite
you know it's funny though i always
thought about that moment like when uh
when i'm gonna die like you know if you
think you're gonna die this guy's real
relaxed
[Laughter]
have you ever thought like if you're if
you know you're going to die like you're
on a plane or something like that yeah
you're going down you're with people and
they know they're going to die and like
there's women there and like you're a
guy i always imagine like everyone
should just like will you whip out your
dick and everybody's gonna stop [ __ ]
i i'd grab her tit she'd grab my you
don't want to be the last person to
touch your dick sure consequences i
of course you think about that you're
like hey pull your dick out and light a
cig those are my two goats
i think the
what's this guy doing what do you mean
what am i doing we're dying
we haven't even taken off yet
i hate flying
i don't know but somebody killed these
overhead lights
dude at the beginning of flight he's
like what he does well i had a dream we
were going down so i want to get a jump
on it
i figured hey what the hell
i don't know man
and those last let's say it's minutes
in those last couple of minutes it would
really be hard to set the mood to get it
sexy that have to be one hell of a
playlist
i'll tell you you're so stupid like you
think some girl is going to want to
touch the middle c guy's dick she's
going she's going across the aisle the
idiot yeah he's going right to first
class
he's not gonna jerk off some dude in
basic economy who boarded the plane last
yeah new [ __ ]
oh yeah that's a good point yeah she
wasn't looking
thank god we're going down well i've i
think he's going with some business dick
or
can't be [ __ ] at least [ __ ] delta
comfort or something
for all she knows you could have been
stand by yeah yeah you're just looking
at it like i'm in boarding group d yeah
yeah so whenever i whenever i take a
flight it's like the zone is high yeah
zone 27
or you get like something on the back
half of the alphabet you're like i'm in
zone m you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] district
nine over here i don't know how many
there are but that ain't good my
boarding time is like two minutes
between the door being open and them
going like you got to catch them
i just never think about comfort when i
fly i'm like i'm going to be up there oh
you're too crazy
that's all i'm all comfort yeah i don't
i don't i don't i don't i splurge in
other areas i don't splurge on the plane
yeah yeah
i do what i got again i'm trying to make
it sound like a choice
but it's like hey i just what do you fly
in are you like are you flying sweats
would you you know what do you got a
go-to outfit you comfy what are you
doing i don't think i i should consider
it more okay because a lot of times i
have a gut and like you know when you
fly with a belt and you sit like that
that's time i wake up with this you know
what i'm talking about a little sword i
gotta get a seat belt extra
that's first order of business i step on
the plane i love how when you get on the
plane you can always tell how skinny or
fat the person was before
who was on before you because you look
at the california oh [ __ ] fat
[ __ ]
but yeah i'll often have the i get that
problem where the belt is
[Music]
so i should get a fly outfit yeah yeah i
should be in sweats
that always annoyed me when you see
somebody i don't like in pajamas getting
on the [ __ ] plane
like i could go to work i dude i'm in
jeans i'd wear this yeah i wear jeans i
respect that clean but casual right
you're a little poo cash i wore shorts
you wear shorts i wear shorts big games
dude
in the middle in the middle of the week
he's definitely he's definitely not
getting a hand job
can i get your number at least
probably in the afterlife
wait so you roll in shorts like middle
of january too if we're going someplace
if i'm ending up someplace warm yeah i'm
stepping off correct oh
yeah do you think i'm [ __ ] pulling up
the [ __ ] miami with a winter coat
like a [ __ ] jerk off you see smart
move though you know how many times i've
like pulled up the cancun with like a
leather jacket
a [ __ ] hoodie and then just i'm
drilling
you look like you're going to [ __ ]
boston now i'm ready to [ __ ] slide
right into the pool you kidding me let's
go smart smart smart yeah i do that too
much
there is a there is an etiquette
there is some people who plan
who are really good flyers yeah and some
people who aren't i'm not a good packer
i'm not a good flyer i do one g paired
uh jeans and then i just count underwear
and socks yeah that's what you're doing
underwear shocks t-shirts
i keep it real i try not to [ __ ] with
the baggage with the bag check right now
although i did realize flying back from
hawaii this time i checked all my [ __ ]
so i'm just rolling around the airport
like i'm in the mall that's nice hawaii
just got back this guy just got back oh
and while we were there vacation uh
girlfriend's sister's wedding oh
mandatory you had to go nice yeah it was
good though if you're gonna go it's good
but it's hawaii just seems like you ever
been no but i heard it's beautiful but
it's like 14 hours long
it's a hike tight it's ten hours but if
you click it out fly direct out of west
chester
no you gotta do like three stops to get
there you gotta fly
you can't westchester in new york are
you kidding me
cam let's talk about the good people
over there at the daily tip presented by
who
mgm pretty classy
that's not that's a big dog that's big
dogs yeah ain't no mom and pop shop no
these guys know what they're doing
here's the bottom line
sports betting information is power
the more you know yeah the closer to the
game uh-huh more up-to-date the
information is yeah the better your
gonna be sitting yeah you gotta stay
ahead of the curve with these guys
things are always changing who knows if
you like to place a better two get on
the daily tip and find out what's really
going on yeah uh as you know i like to
dabble from time to time and a nice
little parlay a nice little taser or
something you got to have the info
unless there's a lot of things are
always changing go to these guys these
guys can give you the insight um
and uh with featured guests they have
bookmakers on audacity insiders bed mgm
experts you always got a fresh take on
the action and someone in the know uh
your friends will be wondering uh
what you what you know that they don't
you'll be dropping gems on them keeping
them like you're on the team or
something
i'm in a front office
uh as much fun as the bet on game it's
even more fun when you've got the inside
scoop uh ready to bet with an edge tune
into the daily tip presented by bet mgm
listen weekdays 6 a.m to 9 a.m eastern
on audacity spotify or your favorite
podcast app there you go do it kippy
stamps.comstamps.comstamps.com say it
one more time for me wait are we talking
about stamps.com sounds good rolls off
the tongue quick the good folks at
stamps.com want you to remember holiday
season post office gonna be all jammed
up hectic hectic long lines if you're a
small business owner all right if you
got a bunch of stuff you got to send out
use stamps.com you get to do it from the
comfort and the quiet of your own home
or home office yeah whether you're
selling online running a business side
hustle stamps.com saves you time and
money during the holidays they really do
get access to all the post office and
ups shipping services you need without
taking the trip you'll get discounts up
to 40 off usps and 76 off ups and you
are done
um
it's easy peasy they let they sent us a
whole package when we signed up with
them it's fantastic they got dude smear
got the scale you got pee pee poop
cranking out i feel like i work at the
post i should be getting benny's i'm
feeling like santa's elbows doing all
the work over here but it saves time and
money uh so this holiday season use
stamps.com save time and money sign up
with promo code garbage for a special
offer that includes a four week trial
free postage digital scale no long term
no long term commitments or contracts
required just go to stamps.com click the
microphone at the top of the home page
enter code garbage one more time
stance.com click the microphone at the
top of the home page enter code garbage
now back
steps.com
holy [ __ ] now it's not bad you get on it
with that i mean that's to me that's
time travel yeah or space travel yes
it's ten hours i'm waking up in a
different time zone i don't know what's
going on yeah i couple [ __ ] tylenol
pm some [ __ ] bloody marys
watch a couple of movies right that's it
yeah what are your videos what are your
vacations looking like see that's what i
was about to say uh when it comes to i i
could see your i could see your lady
liking the trout like nice things yeah
well we did our honeymoon in cancun
all inclusive yeah
what radio station were you with
what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i wanted to save a couple
dollars
how is sammy hagar what the [ __ ] giannis
cancun
how many spring breakers are you staying
with there was too many yeah
it was there was too many you know
there's a kid the five of us got a two
bedroom
you're not even really in the room when
you think about it
what the [ __ ] can [ __ ] you got away with
kids we're only sleeping there yeah well
you know that you know i don't think she
was crazy about it but we had fun
but uh
she wanted to go she comes from a little
bit of cash
yeah we had a big wedding it was she
comes from cash your dad's stock that's
a dog yeah
specialized yeah he's a podiatrist
but he's a chief podiatrist
i don't even know what that that i
figured the whole hat or some of the
army
yeah but she wanted to go to greece in
italy but i was like looking at the
prices and i was like and then i
remembered i got a vacation package i
bought with my ex-girlfriend i still got
to finish up so oh my
that was your honeymoon
does she know that
she's heard
me joke about it
i don't know if she thinks knows it's
real where do you pick up a vacate what
is a vacation package the first raffle
or something i went down there for sure
yeah what happens is you go down there
you've never had that you guys
you you watch a presentation you guys
aren't cancun class where you go to
[ __ ] paris for vacation
i'm a jo
he's he's going in like two weeks i've
made
this kid's gone classy since i last seen
him
you gotta fake it till you make it baby
oh my new year's picture's gonna be in
front of the eiffel tower
i don't know what applebee's you losers
are gonna be at
but i'll be strutting
a pair of shorts on
but i tell you even if i got like a a
little money like a nice chunk of money
i think i still might go all inclusive i
love the convenience i love i just did
it on the dr a couple weeks ago a few
months ago all the closest of nice
that's not the problem
old girlfriend's vacation package that's
the business at hand right now that's
the business hand but i was going to say
if you go to one you need to be watched
you need to go with a chaperone where
they go all right we gotta 86 this guy
at some point
don't tell him with a shrimp part
yeah so it was 1100 off peak you know
140 degrees out there was middle of
august but it was 11 000.
jesus christ
middle summer
and we had a great time yeah we had a
great
nice tour of the agave fields and uh
wait hold on you got to explain this
package thing to me yeah so what they do
is when you go down there on vacation
they scope you out like
exactly what they do and they go hey you
want a free breakfast this kid without
the product they go you want a free
breakfast and you go like that's how
they watched it you watch the
presentation yeah and then they get you
and then they bring in another
no they do it in the hotel like they
they come they like come like isn't it
all free breakfast it's all inclusive it
is all inclusive but they pretend like
they bring you like a special they got
an omelet yeah they got like an omelette
bar or something like you know we'll
meet you over you want me for you know
just here's your oh they they go here's
your person
who can like help tell you about events
and stuff and like
trips you can do and that's how they
rope you in and the next thing you know
you're spending two hours negotiating
with this guy about it for another trip
about how they can package you in
like where you get a discount if you
come regularly for like 10 years that's
a time share yeah it's basically a time
oh man you got time share you want to
you went to a time share honeymoon god
damn yanni
sold yourself out for some brioche
french toast yeah it's on my instagram
all for an omelette yeah it's like two
years ago now but we went to cancun yeah
so how hot class how long was the
package for uh it's six days seven
nights no how many how many you've still
got oh i'm saying you guys want to go to
cancun
i gotta use these [ __ ] things i'm
thinking about getting divorced and
married again just so i can go on
another one
i mean i gotta use them how many i'm
telling my wife remember giannis from
versions well we can go because he got
married i'll go with you [ __ ] guys i
mean three of us go with our ladies
i mean
triple date the more people go the less
it is amongst all of us of course i mean
dude i gonna charge you guys a little
more mcdonald's scratch on the side i
know we're involved in it
i gotta go to cancun for the next 25
years listen listen this stuff sells
itself i'm telling you
the money's in the licenses okay
dude
all you can eat all you can drink i know
but after three days that's too much
they got a brazilian restaurant
they got them in new york guys
but they're free to focus they chow but
you think they're free you just paid up
front that's the beauty of it i just did
one and it's like after i went down with
my i went down to the dr with my boys
boy you guys are going in separate
directions what do you mean you're like
i just went when he's like i'm going to
paris and honolulu
then we're going up to nantucket you're
like yeah i'm going down to mexico city
then we go i'm going down to honduras
for a few days
[Laughter]
nicaragua twice in one year what the
[ __ ] so you just did it all inclusive
yeah that's a lot like you're just like
sweating out that booze after like the
third day the food's all the same it's
like yeah you can't get the nice
restaurants or whatever put on weight
when you go down there oh dude you're
just i'm like drinking beers and i'm
like they're not even doing anything
yeah yeah you wait for like just a
little
opening in your stomach i gotta fill
that yeah
like everyone thinks they're like a
great person till you you go to an
all-inclusive
and then you just realize what kind of
piece of [ __ ] you have like
like putting on the same plate you're
basically going like uh you go down
there and say uh give me infinity of
your resources
[Laughter]
for 900.
i'm only willing to pay 900. here's the
deal if you're gonna run out of [ __ ] or
i'm gonna die
i paid
let's 1100 sure the air conditioner is
cold in the yeah in the room i don't
care how many people are starving in
this third world country i just need
four more extra cheeses
to go now yeah to go
i want to eat them on the beach i need
two to just throw on the floor at your
feet
i mean it's really crazy it's nuts man
it's just like dude there's just like
people taking plates of pasta out to the
beach and you're like what are we doing
this is crazy eat in the restaurant you
can't go anywhere without there being an
option for food yeah everything there's
like a stand everywhere there's like
burgers there's a swim up bar yeah
they're just really bad it's like eating
chicken fingers in the pool that's a bad
luck i have not been to this
all-inclusive yeah but i would like to
go there
[Laughter]
i hear tails you may never leave like
they may have to
not because you don't want to it's just
they may they won't be able to remove
the wall to get you out of here
you eat yourself into your room
god damn that guy in uh 504 stuck it's
funny too when you go to an
all-inclusive because it's all like
couples who are like less than middle
class well that's it brings out the
tough it's a tough crowd
it's a cancun class yeah they end up on
the bar real quick there's a cancun
class it comes with a tattoo yes it
comes with like all all-inclusive rich
people aren't doing all-inclusives
because they're gonna go i don't need to
save the money i'm gonna spend the money
there's a good chance you have a tattoo
and a goatee oh if you're in cancun dude
people were walking up to the bar like
in the lobbies yeah and they bring their
own containers i just noticed you have a
you have a goatee
come on i got the same thing you got
yeah but it's a little darker yeah yeah
yeah you're great santorini something
nice it's expensive though is it no you
don't want it i thought greece was in
the crapper not eleven hundred dollars i
mean eleven hundred wait does that
include airfare with their with airfare
i think for the two of us we were like
1400 bucks
total for a week total
total that's it and it is a nice trip
you dropped 1400 on your honeymoon yeah
what the [ __ ] man he's spending 9 grand
in paris
it'd be nice if her [ __ ] family upped
a few [ __ ] dollars to help me out
god damn it
now getting this wet t-shirt contest so
we can take an uber to the airport i
mean the old man doesn't even drop a
[ __ ] fiver
help out a little bit guys damn it i'm
making two car payments right now if you
go out to dinner with the fam do they
pick up or do you gotta grab them
they're great yeah i'm joking are they
up there too are they up around the same
area they're on island they're on the
island yeah they're on the island that's
a different thing they don't leave the
island people from long island
get out there you got to go out there i
got to go out there yeah these ms-13s
they're worried about everything that's
13. traffic on the northern ms-13s on
the windows it's the weather everything
they find every excuse to
not leave yeah and they're all every
headline every headline they read they
get nervous about oh my god the the new
variant it's all happening democrat i
don't want to catch democrat i'm not
going
what's going around there's a new
variance
there are far left variants yeah they're
like i want to get that fouchy on me
it's like a republican island back there
really yeah oh yeah country club people
country club people but uh long island's
are it's its own breed sure no it's like
another country yeah yeah they don't
like to come to the city a lot
the food is incredible
um but yeah they really don't leave yeah
you know i don't know what whether maybe
it's because you have to go there's only
one way out it's one way in one way out
bottleneck that's traffic you don't deal
with the traffic nice crib on the
in-laws i would assume yeah
we it was we had our uh engagement party
there
really did you make a pretty penny at
the wedding
not as good as i thought we were gonna
really big wedding i was it was a big
wedding it's a little disappointing
really yeah also a couple of comics you
know didn't give a gift
yeah there's a few comics you still
didn't give a gift one of them then
mowed me oh
i've done that wait yeah i've done that
i i just then mowed for the wedding i
was out yeah it's a bad luck it's a bad
luck dude it was a big ven model what
are we talking about
well you know we're talking okay no vet
mowing at a wedding is a bad not at the
wedding we went we went on a nice dinner
the next night we took them to dinner no
a card mate you got to get a card you
got it they seemed okay
it can't be an afterthought like oh yeah
yeah it's about the effort too yeah nice
card you can't stop at a cvs and grab a
card double park the car run in get it
get it get it get a money holder
congratulations the check has to have
your name and address on it you can't
check i'm a cash guy
all right i don't even have a checkbook
cash or check is good
i should check is good just no cash out
yeah you can't sell a wedding you cannot
sell a wedding gift really i thought we
were doing the right thing we said hey
no i did it the only time i ever did it
is because
i didn't it goes right into the cred the
checking yeah that's tacky it's very
tacky there's no class
yeah i'm really uh i'm really making a
turn here
i'm like you can't do that dude but what
you can do is do it all inclusive
for your honeymoon trying to smuggle
shrimp on the plane
i got a pocket pocket full of oysters
wait hold on yeah no it's tacky yeah you
can't do it i got a
ballpark number i'm thinking what you
walked away with
30.
we were uh a little we did better than
that really yeah okay
we did better than that i think it was
around
50. oh it's not
were you in for the wedding were you in
anything i wasn't in i was in yeah i
paid so that's all gravy it was gravy
but i yeah i didn't pay for the wedding
i mean the wedding we had was like a cat
we had a wedding there's like a video of
it nice which is like uh i enjoy
watching okay
because i enjoy watching the video it's
on youtube check out johnny long days
video put it up they they put it up on
youtube
uh there's a video of it there was a guy
with a camera and everything which leads
me to believe that it's on vhs
which i may or may not be wrong guys got
the big camcorder say a little something
to the camera for yanni
looks like the news in the 80s
dude one time i filmed a wedding but
they didn't have enough money for me to
edit it so i just gave them six and a
half hours of raw footage
you just gave them the entire wedding
back to them hey relive this whole
entire thing
second for second one of the game my
camera died during the vows real talk
yeah
yeah it was uh you know there's a
there's a video of it so fifth but i
didn't shell out yeah i didn't have to
shell out that wedding i assume might
have caught him
close six fights or something yeah yeah
yeah
i shelled out though personally i did
shell out for a few things i think i was
in like 10 15. yeah you always pick up
like oh we'll get the limo or the
trolley or the [ __ ] the band
i picked up a bunch of things yeah
we got i got screw cause i'll get the dj
it's just you
what i got the ipod shuffle
[Laughter]
wedding djs are a different friend or
something check for 3 000.
dj yanni p on the ones and twos
guys
you guys want to hear some laura
branigan
gloria
dead cause you know the music's always
got to be a little toned down to uh
appeal to all the age groups
from the windows to the wall
you got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] temptations or something yeah
you gotta throw it you gotta have a
little my girl yeah
yeah you gotta dance with the grandma
the whole thing i love dancing at a
wedding yeah get me cooking at a wedding
yeah i got screwed cause we had a small
wedding
um me and my wife and then we're gonna
have a big party yeah and then corona
hit so i was looking at that party as a
[ __ ] payday walk away with a couple
jihad right but that didn't [ __ ]
happen
i like that
by the way who calls it corona what the
[ __ ]
god damn you said corona what else is it
where did you have yourself this hoax
nobody nobody's co
nobody's coming oh i'm on yani's side
this whole thing's a
is it a bad hoax going around nobody's
called it corona since february 2020.
well that's what takes me back
that's when i got married
where did you have your wedding uh we
just did we did the um
courthouse and then we had a yeah
you had a legal wedding yeah and then we
had a din din
uh at the smith smith rented the
basement out of the smith yeah all right
cheap real cheap doesn't make up for it
though no ceremony now well there's you
know there was some uh you got married
like you were trying to help somebody
get a green card that could have been
happening
[Laughter]
but for
some legal people frankie feds yeah easy
with the
jesus jesus questions
cut all this this guy's a narc
[ __ ] henry hill over here
come to think of the app and all this i
met your wife i've never heard her speak
english
[Laughter]
my name is maria but she speaks let's
see
the first time foley met her fully goes
out listen lady i don't know what he's
telling you but there is other single
guys in america
i thought we had a taken situation
ah yeah
yeah so we made a little money it helped
with the down payment for sure for sure
yeah we put all of it into the dumpster
i might move out there with him and
versi country it up real nice good
yeah i got to get out of the city man
it's wearing on me yeah really wearing
on me yeah nice yard a dog or something
you know we'd have you up there too
you're a good hang thanks yeah you can't
when you live in a small community
you got to vet every single person
you know who's this guy you know this
guy yeah everything's about like who's
this guy like you just pull your gun out
you stand in front of your driveway
you see a van driving slow you're like
who's this yeah yeah
you vouch for this guy this guy kevin
this actually happened like um so there
was this car there's like two cops that
live on our on our hill right
how many houses are on the hill there's
a bunch the big hill so you would say
that's the community the community's
like that hill back there you guys don't
do uh any do you guys do anything
together as a as a group oh yeah yeah
block parties yeah whenever there's like
you know i went to a halloween party up
there and it was like all the neighbors
and stuff okay july part everybody came
a lot of
neighbors what do these other bozos do
what do the other dads do they're all
you know normal jobs normal jobs yeah
normal jobs everybody's cool everyone's
very cool yeah very cool except one guy
who's not exactly on our block but like
the guy's like one of those guys he
doesn't like your dog on his lawn
he's put a camera out that watches the
drive like guys that's rock yeah yeah he
like keep an eye on that guy he's been
up on a mountain too long yeah he's a
little you know but i don't know him i i
just heard stories about him yelling at
people's kids and stuff ah i don't like
that it's not good every neighborhood
has one there one [ __ ] crazy yeah one
jerk yeah so uh yeah but it's nice it's
nice but yeah you got to be very so that
what happened was oh this is a story so
uh true story
so at one point there was just a car
with a stripe on it right it had like it
was like right away
yeah that got a racing stripe on a car a
stripe on it and it was driving slow on
the
guys
block
suburban guys hate a slow car they don't
like you because i made a fast one yeah
you drive through the neighborhood too
fast
i'd rather you zipping around though
this guy's late for work you're driving
slow something's up you're taking
inventory they got the kids riding the
bikes dude everyone in the block was
like who's this [ __ ] car all the
blinds go down if i can see the little
finger cops already the cop's a cop in
new york he's like i'm already calling
my buddy in the local department like
trying to find out everyone's looking at
their ring one day one day this is one
day right
so people are bored out there's nothing
going on [ __ ] so everyone's i thought
and the cop's like don't worry i'm gonna
find out who's whose car this was all
the guy did was drive slow
and have a stripe on his car
his windows were tinted i couldn't make
it out
so i got half the plate
three months go by or something like
that
we order sushi
it's a delivery director this is a
delivery
car comes up with a stripe on it my wife
goes i think that's the same car i was
worried about i'll tackle them get in
the car [ __ ] oh i'll blow your [ __ ]
brains out you make a move i swear to
god i'll waste you it's john from dynamo
sushi take it easy sir
dog give me that [ __ ] sushi [ __ ]
that's the oldest trick in the book yeah
[ __ ] sicko
everyone comes out with shotguns just
holding bags of sushi how you doing mr
pappas we got this whole narrative going
in her head that our [ __ ] community
is under
fire she's trying to bring some goddamn
crunchy spicy tuna
and uh yeah so we told everybody we're
like guys we
we have hard evidence yeah that is just
a guy who's making delicious
so it's like it's i know it wasn't
another car with a stripe that was the
car yeah
he's got a bomb what are the chances
there's a [ __ ] guy who wants to break
into houses with a stripe striping his
car and an uber eats guy no it's just
the ubereats guy same guy yeah yeah he's
got a bomb it's a dynamite roll what the
[ __ ] but i mean i lie to you not that
this was like a big conversation emails
going around text message you're on the
next door app yeah yeah we got we got we
got a little community group on facebook
wow horse the word gets out you got the
ring you rocking the ring oh dude i got
my [ __ ] my house is uh you're on i
mean i'm it's like you're watching a dog
really the only time you're not going to
get out there you get paranoid real
quick oh there's cameras everywhere all
the time you're not going to see some
and angle on my houses if a plane
crashes into it then we're going to lose
dogs
how come we have not seen that footage
it's the most watched building on the
planet
we got three [ __ ] frames i'm not
trying to say something happened but i'm
i'm a little skeptical yeah show me the
tapes johnny wants to see it
yeah i got google i got google
i
[Music]
it's not powered by it's not the
satellite
no you're not you don't have one of
those things that's google earth it's
google earth dude yeah but that's not
you can't can you tap into google and
watch your house live he doesn't work
for the cia what are you talking about
well you can look at your phone and you
can yeah yeah you can see the camera
yeah really you can't see from the top
no i can't see the top oh okay i'm not
jeff bezos he doesn't work for nasa
i thought it was like when you see like
seal team six go in no but you can i
could i could
that's what i thought it was
i could tune in every i'm overdoing it
there's like a camera in the front in
the back yeah no for the listeners or
this place is [ __ ] covered in yeah
don't even think about it and i'm i'm
strapped i got a [ __ ] 22 rifles
[ __ ] tripwire 10 in the clip yeah
it'll take ten it's just a 22 so it'll
take ten to stop you just to stop you
but hopefully it scares you
the pop is just like
you don't even need to wear like when
you go to the range you don't even have
to put headphones on
just wear your earpods
when i was i was on rogan i brought it
up
i just put the clip on my instagram
where i brought it up to rogan he goes
he goes are you shooting squirrels
oh yeah it just feels like i took my
dick out it was limp yeah you can't talk
about a 22 to him
any gun guy yeah any gun guy you can't
talk about 22. no they're always going
like oh that's cute is that for your
daughter or your wife or something why'd
you go like an abrams tank in the garage
yeah it's the i think it's it's the uh
it's one of the legal ones you can get
it's very easy me and virgie got the
guns together yeah yeah you know the
story yeah yeah we told them we were
going out for something else then we
just came back
guns yeah we've seen johnny got guns
yeah we told him we were going like to
get coffee and then we just both came
back with guns and then he made me go at
his
go at him to his house he'll break the
news yeah because you know when the
friend's there just softens the blow
sure he can't really yell at you that
much yeah if a friend's there so listen
i i got a gun i don't have time we both
were carrying [ __ ] guns like we just
went duck hunting
funny thing is i walked in with toilet
paper and a rifle i was like i got babe
what good
wait that's what you got was a rifle
i got a rifle yeah 22 scope
no scope on it laser pointer
what's the flamethrower situation
it just made me think of this story
though i got a this old friend of mine
told me was she uh it was actually an
old girlfriend she was dating a guy who
was like a drug addict
this story always just made me laugh
hard he goes i'm he's like we're out of
toilet paper he's like
i'm going to store to get toilet paper
he didn't come back for three days
and then he came back holding the toilet
paper hey
i respect that though
this is that story always been
[Laughter]
just a responsible irresponsible drug
addict ah
we love it i this is the funnest part
buddy i'm this is the hardest i've
laughed on any podcast you came in
though hot you know what i mean this is
just fun oh it's a good time baby
[ __ ] love hanging out with the wawa
twins
let's go [ __ ] punch a keypad and get
some help
why the [ __ ] you got to be a computer
programmer to order a [ __ ] sandwich
at wawa the ladies standing right there
[ __ ] everything up they were so much
better back in the day make a mistake
you got to go back back back when they
dropped those that rang
havoc through like yeah the trade unions
they didn't know what the [ __ ] they
didn't know what they were there my dad
i was like just ceased getting hoagies
from wow it's a different operation
that's what he's yelling at the guy
i'm gonna order from you i ain't talking
to this [ __ ] food
i don't have email there's no way he's
doing a touch screen to get a [ __ ]
sammy
i'm not using a tv to order a hoagie
[Laughter]
it does seem like a protracted process
it does and what what it was back in the
day now it's very corporate now you have
you know upstanding people working back
there you used to be just people in the
future yeah yeah you need you need
somebody that has a good meth connection
to make a nice
from back in the day they did do a good
job of naming that joint though wawa
because you people in south jersey and
philly are animals we're fiddling let's
get scrap that south jersey i'm sorry i
forgot i got to hit this guy over here
you think i'm crossing the taconi
palmyra bridge crossing like
cross into ben franklin kick rocks yeah
so you philly only when i go down to
shore
catch me in north wild daddy oh yeah
that's flyover country
we [ __ ] cook through voorhees
[ __ ] sicklersville get out of here i
got no time for cherokee
we're moving
but it is aptly named because you guys
are such animals you drink so much
yeah we do
it's good that they name that place a
sound
so it's like whenever you get into the
uber it's just like whatever noise you
make they just take you to the wall yeah
where are you going
[Laughter]
it sounds like wawa that's where he
wants to go hey go to wawa's uh and it's
wawa i get it it's wawa it's wawa it's a
fantastic yeah i love when people get
mad at that like i throw an s on that
like i'm [ __ ] [ __ ] up a classy
name yeah it's called wawa watch
deal with it what's your sandwich spot
up there on the hill
up there the problem is the food up
there is not as great and you're a food
guy right yeah it's tough i'm surprised
it's tough i think it would be i
pictured it would be no the island on
the island the food is good of course
that's all new york yeah
long island's got good food but
you get a decent pizza up there uh you
got to go to connecticut for the decent
pizz but you know what connecticut is
pepe's pepe's is good what the [ __ ] yup
toby mcguire knows what i'm talking
about that's like an hour and a half
away
45 for me you go you'll drive out there
to get pizza [ __ ] of course i'll
drive it like on like a tuesday night
yeah
like an italian you got to go if you
wanna fresh you gotta you know italian
that's an hour and a half i gotta drive
out by the time you get home it's cold
plus you have to stop and do the tesla
five times
i gotta charge up the car i eat it there
i ate it there
all right really where did we go jules
or something what did we do sally's
sally's right down the street he's just
good he's all right
you're telling me i think it's the best
pizza in the world 100 you're telling me
at the at the papa's house on a friday
night it's pizza night we're staying in
we're gonna watch a movie
there's nowhere to order a pizza
go to angelos
tony's pizza what are you gonna do good
no one makes an okay cheese pizza i'm
bringing that [ __ ] pizza really cross
state lines really yeah that's so dude
that since there's tolls involved in it
you get back at nine i mean i grew up in
new york the pizza's got to be right i
can't eat garbage you know you're
putting it back in the oven to warm it
up a little bit yeah if i bring it back
heat it up you got to heat it up you're
doing plain you doing a white what are
you doing you got to go playing you
don't put anything to [ __ ] it up or i do
a clan pie clamp you do a clamp i don't
do it for me
well you know you're from philly
[Laughter]
you guys like [ __ ] like
genuinely upset
i did it yeah it's the second time
you'll miss it hey why don't you go [ __ ]
yourself
you guys throw liquid cheese on [ __ ] i'm
a clam pie guys
shout out to the chief i'm an eclectic
palette
i like clam pies i like crab sticks
i can't wait i can't wait to see the
photos of you in paris yeah walk around
with your eagle hat
go birds with your big gulp slurpee that
you [ __ ] took on the tree on the
plane with you stuck in a boot somewhere
hey frenchie where's the roy rogers
around
huh real quick [ __ ] extra-large diet
we're trying to wet here
coke
coke light what's this [ __ ] yeah
looking at their portions going like
what what are you guys allergic to ice
let's [ __ ] go they don't do the ice
[ __ ] ethiopia put some [ __ ] food
on this plate you know i gotta blow to
get a phantom around this dumbbell jesus
christ
oh god no taki's out there no takis out
there in paris what's a taki you guys
aren't up on tacos
are they in new york yes are they in new
york right now what do you mean
they're running for mayor i don't know
we only heard about them i only ever
heard about them in the midwest you're
talking about a branded doritos like
it's a [ __ ] republican gun
like is it in new york can you open
carry it's like it's a [ __ ] dorito
bag we got to wear a mask around here
what's happening
what are you guys doing over here it's
doritos they're nationwide big toxic is
it tacos
third time he's going to hit me
i'm batting a cycle over here i mean you
know they do i mean they may not have
them that's the reason why you may not
know it
dude i will eat the fruit in a cup and
wawa yeah dude
very fine prepared sandwiches already
just go to the ice box and grab one i
actually love one the breakfast sandwich
with the hashbrown ain't nothing shout
out to the sizzling yeah
i got one now if they run specials you
can't they're like two for three or
something like that they also put a
little cream cheese and the pretzels up
there and the price is nice dude you get
a nice hoagie for like eight bucks out
the door out the door out the door nice
wawa iced tea too is that what you're
doing on the mountain driving go get a
home back in two days well i was in
point pleasant like two days ago and i
stopped at a wawa because i had to
charge up very nice and i charge up at
nice huawei's they charge up at wawa
what's a nice wallet i got the chargers
they got the chargers at the nice wow
and i got a sandwich i always get a sale
with chihuahua on the way back how long
does it take to charge
yeah 40 minutes geez so it's not like a
normal gas train no but you know you
throw it you can throw on netflix in the
car you can yeah you know they got the
tv so yeah yeah
it's a it's a thing
it's a downside if there is a downside
to the tesla it's that yeah in the car
i did eat it in the car nice yeah i did
have i did it in the car is that a norm
for you or not a norm for you
also let's be warm for me are you
dipping
on the ride back from connecticut of
course yeah what do you mean you're
folding up one slice yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah you gotta have one
coming back light yeah it looks like
miss pacquiao
skimming off the top yani's kim
always make that move hey they only gave
me two slices i don't know what happened
yeah it's coming back seven slices yeah
yeah
[ __ ] seven slices in connecticut you
believe these [ __ ] idiots
all right let's get the [ __ ] out of here
you honestly thank you so much
questions
next time do it next time what do you
got cooking what do you got coming up
long days look check out the podcast
long days uh go to my website i'll be at
mohegan sun coming up the 16th through
the 18th check my dates
giannispappiscomedy.com
check it out we love it kippy what do
you got for him guys kevin ryan comedy
on all social media uh check out the
patreon the youtube subscribe to the
youtube channel we got something
dropping subscribe right now don't miss
out click click we love you peace peace